Silvia's growing tomato plants and
studying their heights here is her data
so the beefsteak tomato type had a
height of 3 3 and 1/4 feet roma 2 and
7/8 feet cherry 3 and 1/2 feet and they
asked us what is the difference between
the heights of the beefsteak between the
heights of the beefsteak so that's that
one right over there and the Roma and
the Roma tomato plants so they want us
to find the distance between these two
heights so this cherry tomato height
this was really unnecessary for the sake
of this problem so we want to find the
difference in this these two heights so
we want to subtract the smaller of these
from the larger of these so we're really
trying to evaluate what 3 and 1/4 minus
2 and 7/8 is minus 2 and 7/8 now the
first thing that I like to do is convert
both of these into mixed numbers so
let's store it sorry they're already
mixed numbers to convert both of these
into improper fractions so 3 and 1/4 is
the same thing as 3 plus 1/4 which is
the same thing as 12 forts 12 forts plus
1/4 that's the same thing as 3 and 1/4
and from that we're going to subtract 2
and 7/8
2 and 7/8 is the same thing as 2 plus
7/8 2 is the same thing as 16 over 8
plus 7 over 8 so this is essentially
what we are trying to figure out now
what is 12 fourths plus 1/4 it's
thirteen fourths 13 over 4 and then
what's 16 8 plus 7 8 well that's 23 over
8 so this is going to be minus 23 over 8
now we're subtracting to or subtracting
one fraction from another but we have
different denominators so we can't make
sense of this until we have the same
denominator and so what is the least
common multiple of these two
denominators of both 4 and 8 what is the
smallest number that is divisible by
both 4 & 8 well 8 is divisible by 8 and
8 is also divisible by 4
or so if we can rewrite 13 over 4 as
having 8 as a denominator then we are
all set so let's try to do that so we're
going to write both of these as 8 with 8
as a denominator this one already has it
so 13 over 4 I'm going to have it with 8
as a denominator so if we multiplied the
denominator to get from 4 to 8 we have
to multiply the denominator by 2 so in
order to not change the value of the
fraction we have to multiply the
numerator by the exact same value we got
to multiply it by 2 so this becomes 26
over 8 and from 26 over 8 we're going to
subtract 23 over 8 and so this is going
to be over 8 26 26 - 23 - 23 which is
equal in too and we deserve our drumroll
now 26 minus 23 is 3 so it's 3/8 so the
difference between the heights of the
beefsteak and and Roma tomato plants 3/8
and everything we've been doing in so
far has been in feet so 3/8 of a foot